okay hi everyone thank you for being
here today my name is fedora petrenko
and I'm a first-year som FES joint
degree student and in a moment I'll be
introducing Joe in Vic sparkfun today's
speaker first I'd like to make a couple
announcements this talk is co-sponsored
by the Saban sustainable venture speaker
series and the blueprint for efficiency
webinar series and this talk is being
broadcast live so if you have a question
please remember to press the little
microphone button at your desk so the
Saban's the Saban price supports Yale
student and faculty efforts to start
sustainable for-profit businesses
through cash prizes totaling $25,000 the
competition provides feedback from
professional judges extensive mentoring
from faculty and opportunities for
participants to meet and pitch their
ideas to venture capitalists and
industry leaders and the blueprint for
efficiency webinar series provides a
platform for leading practitioners and
researchers to explore energy efficiency
through the lenses of behavior policy
finance and technology and just one more
announcement so applications for the
Sobotka seed stage venture grants are
due on November 25th the Yale Center for
business and environment is soliciting
proposals to support student faculty
efforts to launch new startup ventures
in the field of business and the
environment the application deadline is
8 p.m. on tuesday november 25th for the
opportunity to receive a
ten-thousand-dollar seed stage venture
grant to launch your business and if you
guys want any more information on any of
the above just visit see bae yale edu
that's CB euy yale edu that's the center
for business and environments website so
without further ado at joe indvik as an
entrepreneur and consultant focused on
scaling solutions for energy efficiency
and developing new approaches for
financing efficiency technologies he's
the co-founder and president of spark
fund a washington DC startup that has
developed a truly innovative financing
solution for small and medium-sized
energy efficiency projects prior to
spark fund Joe is a consulting
in the climate change and sustainability
practice at ICF international where he
led the development of a new advisory
service for energy efficiency finance
he's worked with diverse clients from
hospitals to higher education and from
fortune 500 companies to federal
agencies optical of making smart
investments to improve building energy
efficiency and reduce environmental
impact before sparked fund Joe is at
Dartmouth call and before I CF Joe is at
Dartmouth College where he received a
degree in economics and environmental
studies and that's actually where I
first met him had the great pleasure of
working with Joe on the Dartmouth
College Green revolving loan fund and I
can tell you he's a true visionary and
leader in this space so without further
ado it's a great honor to introduce Joe
you know Mike thanks buddy alright
thanks fodor awesome to be back at Yale
guys actually a funny ad a funny blast
from the past about Yale a couple days
ago after a couple drinks my girlfriend
and I decided to break out our old
college entrance essay to see how
terrible they were and i finally found
mine and at that point I had no idea I
wanted to do energy efficiency or
climate change or anything like that so
I wrote an essay about why history is
important to me and it had this terrible
line in there about how history is like
a spotlight shining out from the past
and illuminating the path before us and
I'm just cringing the whole time that
I'm reading this for some crazy reason
Yale actually didn't let me and though I
applied early action so I had to flee to
the frigid north and attend a little
school called Dartmouth up there which
actually turned out to be a pretty good
decision but in all seriousness it's
good to be back I got pretty familiar
with Yale on the Yale community when I
was applying and it's really a warm
amazing place to be so both the
undergraduate campus and School of
Management and FES so thank you guys for
the honor of coming to talk about
sparkfun I'm going to just jump right in
here actually before I do that to talk
about unlocking the small energy
efficiency project market and
particularly how better financing smart
technology and new startups like spark
fund and others can make that happen so
in the next 30 minutes I want to talk a
little bit about Who I am and why I live
and breathe energy efficiency finance
I'm going to talk about some of the
market barriers to getting efficiency
finance done particularly in the small
project space I'm going to talk about
how we think at least spark fund is
chained
game on small project finance for
efficiency and at the end I'm going to
issue you all the kind of a big hairy
difficult challenge which i think is the
best way of expressing one of the
monumental task we're facing and solving
the energy efficiency challenge and
getting capital deployed at scale in the
economy so something I want kind of
everybody to think about and have a good
discussion about during QA hopefully so
if it were covered this pretty well but
my background I started off at Dartmouth
eventually gravitated towards an
economics environmental studies
background and helped work with fedora
for door was the real mastermind on the
Dartmouth green revolving fund by the
way we just sort of kind of got the
wheels turning but established a
million-dollar revolving fund to finance
energy efficiency projects and then
recapture the saving from those projects
and revolve them back into the fund for
continual investment and after Dartmouth
I left and went to ICF international
which is a consultancy in DC we I did an
interesting mix of kind of federal
policy work supporting EPA on climate
and energy policy but more interestingly
i also got to work as a essentially a
sustainability management consultant so
i got to walk into fortune 500 companies
federal agencies nonprofits whole range
of other organizations and help them
green their operations so it was looking
at everything from facility upgrades and
you know pure engineering type upgrades
all the way to better incentive
alignment so that facility managers were
incentivized to conserve energy so we
got to get kind of a full full spectrum
perspective on how efficiency works at a
whole wide range of organizations and
the moment I realized I wanted to
dedicate probably the rest of my life
and career working on energy efficiency
was we were doing an ashtray level one
audit of an equipment distributor the
descriptor shall remain nameless but it
was a fairly large distributor that
primarily dealt in energy efficiency
equipment so light bulbs at hvac systems
and a whole range of other equipment
types and we walked in to do an ashtray
audit of this building and there was
something weird going on on the wall so
we said to the facility manager what's
that up on the wall and he said well we
had an old HVAC unit kind of jammed in
there and we decided we didn't want it
anymore so we pulled it out and we
stapled a bunch of cardboard up there in
the middle of the winter to keep the
cold out and we never really wound up
fixing it cuz I don't really have any
financial incentive to conserve energy
in this building there were literally
efficiency equipment supplies sitting
two miles over in this warehouse that's
when I realized that efficiency isn't
just a game
of economics it's a game of behavioral
economics right and there's a key
difference there you can talk about the
financial returns of efficiency all day
long but there are some really key
behavioral economics even even
psychological components to getting
energy efficiency deployed and that the
incentives aren't aligned correctly and
if the services provided are sort of
aligned with the needs of the business
then it's not going to happen that was
one of the core kind of reasons I
decided to work more on the space and
then I worked with a couple of guys at
ICF who ended up being my co-founders on
sparkfun so two other consultants from
ICF plus a fourth co-founder that we
brought in from Intuit the financial
software company that manages TurboTax
and quicken and some other financial
software packages and found its parkland
in February of this year so I'll talk a
little bit more about sparkfun later but
really the kind of genesis of spark fund
was getting to work with a range of
clients on their energy efficiency
challenges and realizing that small
project energy efficiency there's one of
the biggest gaps in financing in the
country and we need startups that are
specifically focused on that segment of
the market so the door tells me pretty
much everybody here is familiar with the
basics of energy efficiency so we're not
going to go to in the weeds here but
there's three three important points to
remember energy efficiency is a massive
potential market mackynzie and others
estimate that it's approximately a four
hundred billion dollar plus potential
market for efficiency investments that's
domestic net present value positive
investments with current technologies so
that market is only going to grow
obviously energy efficiency is a good
investment at the organization level
it's very common to see three year
paybacks on efficiency in the average
building portfolio everything from
churches and charter schools all the way
to commercial and of course if you ask
me energy efficiency is the key to
stopping climate change it's actually
been estimated that it's possible to
achieve about a twenty three percent
reduction in u.s. building energy
consumption just by making that net
present value positive four hundred
billion dollar investment so twenty
three percent cut it's pretty dramatic
and things are only getting better so
this is one particular example of how
technologies and energy efficiency are
evolving but that gray line there you
see is for LED technologies it's the
dollars per unit of light generated
basically and how its evolved over the
last decade that's almost two orders of
magnitude decrease and how much it costs
to produce a woman of light from an LED
light bulb so LEDs are kind of the most
extreme example but there are a whole
range of other efficiency technologies
that are getting better and better every
year from a technical perspective and
thus more and more attractive from an
investment perspective so this market is
only going to get bigger so the question
is why isn't that investment happening
we clearly aren't seeing deployment of
capital into the energy efficiency
projects at the rate that it should be
for the ekket kind of the economically
optimal rate so why exactly is that
happening well let's first identify how
do we know there's a problem in energy
efficiency finance to start with well we
know that potential returns have
outpaced investment pretty dramatically
so if you can achieve a 30-percent ROI
with a three year payback project in the
average building portfolio and capital
isn't flowing into those opportunities
and capturing them clearly there's
something structurally wrong about the
way that we're deploying money into
efficiency projects second is that
that's that's the sort of top-down
approach if you take the bottom-up
approach approach and go directly to
customers and ask them about financing
customers pretty unanimously say and
when I say when I say customers I mean
managers of buildings and everything
from the commercial to the nonprofit
space pretty unanimously say that they
cannot consistently find capital for
small project energy efficiency upgrades
I'll talk a little bit more about some
of the specific surveys later but
they're telling us it's a problem and
third if you look at the economy wide
sort of the system's level approach here
clearly deployment of energy efficiency
is way below the economic and social
optimum from the perspective of
pollution from the perspective of the
energy budgets that local small
businesses and communities are sinking
into energy usage from the perspective
of climate change pollution and a whole
range of other impacts it's pretty
obvious when you look at the numbers
that our deployment is below where it
should be so we now have a problem but
it's particularly it's a structural
problem the market is structurally
underserved by existing financing
options and what I mean by this is it's
not the kind of problem you can sort of
stand by and watch wait a couple of
years and the capital will show up there
are innate structural problems the way
that money is deployed in the energy
efficiency space and structural problems
with the way that current financing
players are addressing the space that
make it structurally impossible for the
capital will flow as it should right now
so it's a hairy problem to be to be
addressed but one that can be solved
with the right technologies and the
right approach so everybody kind of has
they're their pet 10 reasons that energy
efficiency isn't happening if you Google
blogs you'll find all kinds of top ten
and top five lists and barriers to
energy efficiency I think the small
project market is one of the biggest if
not the biggest barriers to getting
efficiency done and one of the least
discussed so I want to kind of frame
this problem for you quickly here so we
have a 400 billion dollar economy-wide
opportunity in energy efficiency a
statistic that blows my mind is that
fifty percent of building energy
consumption happens in buildings that
are less than 50,000 square feet so it's
buildings that are essentially a small
supermarket or smaller so you rule out
skyscrapers a lot of university
buildings office spaces even read even
ruling out residential this is only
commercial you rule out all those
buildings the remaining buildings that
are left like small businesses and
churches and charter schools and
synagogues and community centers and
those types of buildings small
commercial buildings constitute about
fifty percent of the energy consumption
in the US by extrapolation we can assume
that there they then roughly represent
about fifty percent of the efficiency
investment opportunity so we have
roughly a 200 billion dollar small
project opportunity here the number
that's the real kicker is that sixty
percent of those projects lack financing
so there was a study done a couple of
studies have corroborated this but
there's a study done by jewel assets
recently that actually pulled several
thousand energy managers facility
managers and contractors and said okay
tell me the list of efficiency projects
that you're considering number one
number two tell me if you have financing
for that project and a whopping sixty
percent of the projects under five
hundred thousand or so reported that
they do not have access to capital so
that's no access to internal capital and
external capital is either unavailable
or to high-priced or difficult to obtain
to make sense so there is a massive 120
billion dollar at least small project
opportunity to be addressed here and
that is exactly why we found its
parkland so sparkfun has a dual mission
of both unlocking the small project
energy efficiency market in some ways
that I'll talk about it a little bit but
also in creating a new asset class of
standardized small project efficiency
investments that investors can feel
comfortable place in their capital in so
a little bit of background on spark fund
started off with four co-founders is now
grown to a team of 13
since februari of this year so it's been
pretty rapid growth we raised the seed
round in February and are just about to
close on a series a round currently a
much larger series a we're based in
Washington DC and spark fund the one
thing you should know about our
particular financing product is it is at
its core it is a straight equipment
lease it's the same kind of equipment
lease you would get if you're releasing
a copier or a printer or a forklift or a
truck or any other type of industrial
commercial equipment but we've layered
some technology and some kind of
contract structures on top of that to
make it a lot more user friendly and
accessible for small for small projects
so before I jump into the details of
what we're doing at sparkfun you know
anybody anybody can incorporate a
company and raise some capital talk to
some investors and finance a couple of
projects but to truly say that we're
addressing the small project market we
have to overcome those structural
barriers I was talking about that are
preventing capital from flowing into the
space right we want to be market
transformative not just a small startup
that does you know a couple million
dollars in deals here there so the three
barriers that we've really focused on
trying to address with our technology
and our business approach are these
first and I think the most important is
transaction costs so this is one of the
reasons that you don't see a ton of big
financial players getting involved in
the small project finance market is they
have configured themselves to be large
relatively obtuse management heavy
organizations who have long lengthy
diligence processes and you know pay
senior executives three four hundred
thousand dollars a year to diligence
projects personally it's very hard for
them to shift to look at get small
projects so if they have a fixed
transaction cost of says this is a big
bank we're talking about for example if
they have a fixed transaction cost of
fifty thousand dollars for every deal
they do if it's a five-million-dollar
deal that's fine if it's a
two-hundred-thousand-dollar deal they've
just destroyed their margins just by
moving into that segment of the market
so being very aggressive about getting
transaction costs down is one of the
keys to doing this project they're doing
this sector right second is it's a
highly disagree gated market and this is
not something not everybody appreciates
but there are about 10,000 contractors
installing energy efficiency equipment
in the small project space so this is
everything from almost literally two
guys in a truck in the Midwest screwing
in light bulbs to medium-sized energy
service companies menu
facturers vendors a whole range of other
service providers but these contractors
tend to work in sort of disaggregated
regional markets sometimes they'll only
work in a single state with a single
technology type others will work
regionally with different technologies
so they're not standardized they all
sort of speak a different language they
work in different sectors and different
geographic regions but what investors
want most of all is standardization and
they're in their deals and it's very
hard for them to get comfortable with
efficiency as a new asset class if they
can barely understand the market that's
generating that asset class so one of
our biggest challenges is to aggregate
that project market up into investable
tranches and then third is that bigger
is not always better when it comes to
financing structures so one of the
trends that we've seen over the last ten
years or so is a fancier and fancier for
lack of a better word contract
structures for efficiency finance we
started off with this I whole idea of an
energy savings performance contract
where a company like Siemens or Johnson
Controls will come in to a university or
a big a big company and simply do all
your energy efficiency for you you get
to keep a small chunk of the profits
from that but they get to keep the
majority of the savings so it's a
vertically integrated management heavy
very hands-on approach to energy
efficiency and we've seen a lot of
riffing on that recently we've now seen
energy savings agreements and managed
energy savings agreements and a whole
range of other contract structures but
they're only applicable to the large
market million-dollar-plus projects at
minimum usually five million or more
which obviously doesn't represent the
majority of the market and the trend has
been towards more and more complexity in
those contracts and very few of the
finance ears who are participating in
those new markets are looking back at
the small project market and figuring
out how to streamline and reduce
complexity and increase accessibility to
the small project market so one of our
goals is to kind of turn not necessarily
turn that train around because I think
it's a good development for the large
project market but to think in a totally
new asymmetrical way about how to
streamline financing down to its core
pieces for the small projects so a
couple of the specific ways that we
accomplish that going to talk about
spark funds three core value
propositions so the first is the way
that we aggregate projects and the way
that we do so cost-effectively so
there's sort of three pillars of our
project aggregation approach I think the
first and the most important is that we
do almost no direct to cust
marketing all of our projects or at
least the vast majority of them come to
us through our installer network so we
have an installer of network of many
dozens of installers manufacturers
developers utility program implementers
essentially anybody who's already out
there in the market selling energy
efficiency we package our financing
along with their sales process and then
we equip them with software tools to
easily originate deals for us so that
gets our customer customer acquisition
costs through the floor because we can
have a single partner who might bring us
50 or 100 customers in a given year and
that's one relationship we have to
manage rather than 100 relationships we
have to manage I'll talk a little bit
more about those software tools in a
second we also have a very data-driven
approach to pipeline management for
projects so one of the challenges with
small projects is that in order to get
to an appreciable scale you have to do a
large volume of small projects right a
hundred million dollar deals is a very
different beast than 100 million dollar
deal from a management perspective so we
use an almost statistical approach to
think about pipeline management so we
use Salesforce the CRM solution or
customer relationship management
solution many of you probably run into
in order to do some really rigorous
tracking of our pipeline because if you
think about originating a hundred deals
for us means we probably have to have
three to five hundred project leads to
start with assuming you know or even a
pretty aggressive conversion rate so
that means managing many dozens of deals
per day per sales manager so what we've
done is essentially taking the
Salesforce platform and built some
additional tools on top of that to be
very statistical about our pipeline
management so we can understand when a
project comes into our pipeline where it
drops out you know if the customer says
no at some point we know why it happened
how big the project was what the nature
of the customer was why they dropped out
a whole range of other data about that
it can start to count and compile some
essentially infrared inferential
statistical analysis of why pipeline
works in some places and doesn't work in
others so we might find that in small
businesses tend to drop out of the
process when we ask them for their their
financials they might not have their
financial statements prepared because
they're small and they're not that
organized you might find that larger you
know churches and charter schools for
example might drop out when we get to
the pricing case of the process where
they didn't realize that the cost of
capital was his high it was going to be
and therefore they dropped out of the
process
so we have a very good keen data-driven
understanding of how that whole how the
market perceives smart fun and then
third we have what can only be described
as a borderline neurotic attention to
workflow efficiency this is a key
strategy for us for getting transaction
costs low so everybody it's Burke fund
is a huge Excel and process nerd so one
of the first things we did was take the
entire project onboarding process from
the time that the contractor brings us a
deal all the way if your diligence
impressing it documenting it executing
it doing the transactions and closing it
out took that entire process and mapped
it out in excel at excruciating detail
so we know every email that goes between
every person what it's what's attached
to it and what the next step is and that
has to really really cooling sort of
important benefits first is that
onboarding for employees becomes
incredibly easy I could take a fresh
college graduate who wants to be a Sales
Account Manager train them for you know
five hours and basically could have them
doing ninety percent of the project
process because it's also well
documented it sort of divorces it from
the individuals knowledge and sort of
makes it into a neutral process that
anybody can follow but more importantly
it also lets us be very data-driven in
the way that we think about process and
let's just do some cool analysis to
figure out where exactly in our in our
comp come to company's business
operations the inefficiencies are and
then build automation tools and software
and process improvements to shore those
up so one interesting analysis I'd like
to show you we can't quite do this yet
because we're relatively early stage but
this is something my kind of vision for
what our process efficiency approach is
going to look like so through the
Salesforce platform we're going to be
able to track every single action that
each account manager takes when they
take it and how long it takes so we can
say okay there were two days that
elapsed between the project coming to us
and giving a pricing offer and there
were three days of elapsed before the
next step and we can also measure the
level of effort or mount of staff time
essentially spent on managing that step
so once we get enough data here we can
sort of plot a neat graph like this
where we can see each stage and the
project onboarding process on the x-axis
you can see how long it's taking in days
and on the y-axis you can see how much
staff time is taking so we can look at
this and say okay you know it makes
sense that the
application stage is actually not very
intensive in terms of our own internal
staff time but it's taking a long time
because where the customer has to
respond to questions about their
financing application and they're
delaying I don't want to do it that kind
of thing or we could look at the
technical review stage and say okay that
makes sense it doesn't take us very long
to do it but we have to invest a lot of
staff time or in our in-house engineer
has to look at this spend five or ten
hours on the deal so we're spending a
lot of time there and a lot of
transaction costs so we can ultimately
do with this data is look
comprehensively across our whole process
and say okay how do we get cost
efficiencies by sort of smashing this
graph down and how do we get volume
efficiencies by smashing it inward and
reducing the total turnaround time on on
projects so the second key and I'm going
to go pretty far into the weeds serious
I think you guys might be interested in
seeing some of the cool installer facing
and customer-facing tools we're building
so as far as the Installer experience
one thing you got to remember about
installers particularly these small
project installers is they have a sort
of love hate relationship with finance
so on the one hand they're losing a lot
of deals because their customers don't
have the capital so we've heard numbers
ranging from twenty to forty percent of
the projects that a contractor proposes
actually gets to the proposal stage
completes a technical assessment on and
presents to the customer up to forty
percent of those the customer says no
because they don't have financing so
that's a lot of lost time and energy and
cost for that contractor so if the
contractor can then have a ready-made
financing solution to offer to that
customer on the spot it's a huge boon
for them and lets them close on more
deals but the reason the kind of flip
side of that is that some financing
solutions take a very long time to
implement so if you look at some state
financing programs or some utility
financing programs the turnaround time
on those programs can be three to six
months or more sometimes so if a
contractor has to kind of wait around
for that whole process to be approved
they're very likely going to lose that
customer and lose the deal so from a
contractor's perspective you know they
might close on twenty percent more deals
with financing but if it takes some
thirty percent longer to close on those
deals then it's not obviously a net
positive for them and they're going to
move on so the key to offering financing
to go along with small project sales for
contractors is to be quick simple
streamlined and non-disruptive of their
normal sales process you have to
integrate seamlessly
the way that they already have
conversations with customers so a few of
the ways that we're doing that one is
that we're moving towards a custom
online CRM interface for contractors so
this would be essentially like currently
it's all website based will eventually
be a platform that a contractor would
log into and propose a project so they
could say here's the project here's some
basic details about the project click
enter and it gets shot into our system
and starts going through all the steps
that I described before and then
whenever an action is required from the
contractor like okay now it's time to
notify your customer to submit the
financing application or now it's time
for you to revise your technical specs
they get a little notification through
the CRM so it becomes a one-stop-shop
for that contractor really simple light
touch approach for them to understand
where all of their projects are and kind
of manage them seamlessly eventually
we're very aware that there's sort of
what I call tool fatigue in the market
where everybody has their own CRM
solution right so piling another serial
on top of that isn't always the best
approach so we're looking at some API
driven solutions where we might be able
to piggyback on top of and contractors
existing CRM solutions and actually
offer API integration with the sparkfun
interface it's kind of a pie in the sky
vision right now but I think one that's
that's realizable in future as I said
before we offer direct sales process
integration to the point where we equip
that contractor with the tools to
actually talk about spark fund in the
same conversation where the customer
says I can't do this i don't have
capital and the kind of ultimate
culmination of that is we would like to
eventually provide a spark fun ipad so
this would be a spark fund piece of
technology we hand to every contractor
and it's preloaded with our pricing tool
so they can spin up a pricing estimate
for the customer on the spot it's
preloaded with the basic least language
or the customer can review what the
lease is going to look like it might
even have a little bubble you could
click that would pop up with a spark
fund customer service representative to
talk through any possible problems so
the whole idea here is to take the
entire financing experience and condense
it into a single streamline iPad
experience which is something that
nobody is really doing in a small
project market yet and then on the
customer front dealing with customers is
a whole other beast one of the most
important things to remember is that
when you're dealing with a fortune 500
or with you know a campus like Yale Law
organizations like that have dedicated
staff whose job it is to think all day
long about energy and sustainability
right energy manager or sustainability
manager is kind of what Fedora used to
do at Dartmouth most of all
organizations don't have that benefit so
the person you're going to be engaging
with as a financing partner is a CFO a
CEO a you know small business owner
that's working 80-hour weeks and they
can be they must be forgiven if energy
efficiency isn't the number one priority
on their list so your task is a
financing partner and spark funds task
is to make this as streamlined and
simple and experience for them as it can
be so I have what I like to call the
before coffee test so if you guys are
like me you probably aren't capable of
like higher-order thinking before you've
had your coffee in the morning so the
whole point is that the spark fund
experience can be something that you can
do before coffee so it doesn't require
an hour long conference call it doesn't
require a lot of super critical thinking
it's like here's the thing you have to
sign here's the next step you have to
take boom boom boom and now you have
your financing that's really the goal
that where they were getting towards so
in terms of the specific customer
experience I actually want to show you
this rather than tell you this I'm just
going to go through this real quickly
and then demo one of our online tools
but we have an online application so the
customer can submit all their financial
information online we have a pricing
tool that they can play with online to
actually get a pricing estimate in real
time we have a two-page lease this is
something I'm unusually proud of I
wasn't really expecting to be innovating
much around legal documents in this
world but it turns out that the
complexity of contract structures is
actually one of the most one of the
biggest barriers to getting efficiency
done you hand a small business owner a
50-page lease that covers every possible
downside risk scenario half the time
they're just not even going to look at
it or even more dangerously they might
sign it without understanding it and
therefore wind up defaulting or you know
not behaving correctly under the
contract so getting things simple
streamlined and transparent is super
important so we have what I could have
called a legal cost-benefit analysis
which it turns out is something that
lawyers are not very good at but
economists really good at which is when
you look at it legal document look at
every pivot provision in there and
figure out okay if something goes wrong
and we have this provision how much
money are we going to save times what's
the likelihood that that thing is
actually going to go wrong so if it's if
it's significant damage from going wrong
but has an incredibly low likelihood of
happening you can probably just remove
that
from the contract you make the business
decision to take the commercial risk in
favor of making the entire document more
understandable and making sure the
customer gets the contract structure
that you're working under so I didn't
really expect to be diving into the
world of legal documents this heavily
but it turns out it's an area that's
that's ripe for innovation and then
finally we offer fully automated payment
so there's no invoicing there's no check
writing or anything like that it's all
deducted directly from the customers
bank account so it's simple and quick I
still do a quick demo sit here you guys
can see that okay so this is the
experience that the customer would have
if they log on to the website so if I'm
a customer and I'm thinking about doing
an energy efficiency project and I don't
really know if I want to do this yet I'm
not sure about the financing I kind of
want to see some basic numbers I can log
in and actually enter cost the project
the savings that's going to generate for
me and the lifetime of the project and
then I can actually see a graph of the
savings that will result if I go with
spark fund financing so the orange here
is the monthly lease payments that I'm
making over the duration of the spark
fund lease and the green is the savings
that I'm going to generate from that
project after the lease and what's
really cool about this is i can select
different pricing solutions depending on
what my financial objectives are so if i
want to minimize my interest rate and be
done with the least as quickly as
possible i can slide this all the way
over here so i'm going to make i'm going
to pay more than my my monthly savings
for the first few months but after that
i get to keep all the savings and own
the equipment if I care more about
near-term cash flows that I care about
interest rate minimization then I can
slide it all the way over to the right
as you can see i'm actually getting to
keep a little bit of the savings during
the least itself i'm only paying this
percentage of those savings to meet the
lease payments and then after the lease
I get to keep all those savings so we're
not guaranteeing savings under this
model but we're helping the customer
understand how Elise is going to work in
the context of savings this is something
that traditional leasing companies have
not done very well at all if you look at
a normal lease it's a 40 page document
and then there's one number there this
is how much you have to pay us every
month the key about energy efficiency is
it's not you shouldn't be focused on the
payment you should be focused on the
the savings generative aspect of
efficiency it's actually saving you
money and it's even saving you money net
of the lease payment that you're already
making so what I think is powerful about
this approach is it reframes energy
efficiency finance in terms of the
savings that you get to keep rather than
in terms of the payments that you have
to make I think that's a key kind of
psychological shift we also have a kind
of cost of delay metric here so it's
important to kind of prod the customer
to understand that the longer they wait
on doing energy efficiency the more
money they're going through out the
window so we kind of estimate those
numbers for them and if they decide okay
you know this sounds pretty cool I know
this isn't the final pricing estimate we
still have to do our credit underwriting
and risk-based pricing to adjust this
but the customer says okay that looks
pretty interesting I'd like to go to the
next step they can go great to the
financing application which is all
online they can scroll down there's some
other basic information another back
sheet and income statement and then
they're off and running so once they
click Submit it'll Shepherd them through
the whole rest of the prime alone I'd
love to get feedback on that model too
during the QA but one final point i'd
like to make and one sort of challenge
that i often think about in fact pretty
much every morning I wake up I think
about solving this challenge and I think
it's one that that all energy innovators
anybody who wants to make energy
efficiency happen at scale needs to be
thinking about it needs to be solving if
we're really going to tackle this
problem at the scale we need to so
here's the setup you can think about the
investor demand that's out there in the
world as a positive charge and you can
think about the energy efficiency
investment opportunity the projects
themselves as a negative charge we have
good data and good knowledge from our
general understanding of the market that
there are tons of investors out there
who want to place capital to energy
efficiency they just haven't gotten over
that hump of accepting it as an asset
class yet we also know that there's this
400 billion dollar economy-wide
opportunity to invest in efficiency the
goal for us innovators in the finite
space is to build the wire between those
two charges it's to build the mechanism
the financing vehicles that are going to
connect the capital to the opportunity
so that wire could take the form of new
financial products like leasing it could
also take the form of new consulting
service offerings that help that help
customers understand the benefits of
finance better like
one that I helped build at ICF or it
could take the form of new programs that
large companies like adidas has a really
innovative program where they developed
a two-million-dollar fund to invest in
internal energy efficiency projects
that's managed essentially like a
venture capital fund so this wire can
take a lot of different forms but
there's three attributes it has to have
and this is where the real kind of
rubber hits the road so the first is
transmission efficiency so like any
electrical system if you're losing a
bunch of energy along the line it's not
going to be a very efficient system and
in the analogous thing and the finance
world is of course transaction costs so
as money moves from investors to
projects it has to be transaction
efficient has to be low-cost it has to
move quickly second is accessibility if
that wire only connects the the biggest
10% of projects to the wealthiest 10% of
investors you're not really solving the
whole problem so whatever new financing
products we build have to address the
full spectrum of the efficiency market
all the way from the 20 million dollar
massive you know university-wide
programs all the way down to ten
thousand dollar residential upgrades or
less but they should also ideally
address the full range of investor
demand right but things like
crowdfunding and impact investing and a
whole range of other kind of new
emerging investor models we don't wanna
just be taking capital from traditional
sources we want to be taking it from the
full spectrum of investors in third I
think this is the most important thing
to think about is we need massive
capacity for capital deployment in this
country it's a 400 billion dollar
opportunity now it'll probably be an 800
billion dollar opportunity you know all
else stays equal in the next couple of
decades we need to be thinking in terms
of billions and tens of billions of
dollars flowing into this market so
small small scale financing solutions
are great solving a problem in a niche
market is great but at the end of the
day we need large a big fat wire that
can connect billions and tens of
billions of dollars in capital to
efficiency projects so that's this is
the thing I sort of wake up every day
thinking about trying to solve I think
companies like spark fund are a good
start and addressing an underserved
segment of the market but there's a
whole lot of other innovation to be had
with new technologies new financing
products and new business processes here
so something to keep in mind and with
that I think we'll do questions
yeah yeah I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit more about the
structure of your company I mean in the
sense of are you a commercial bank are
you a hedge fund like you know how
exactly are you distributing funds and
are there regulations that you're
subject to because of that there are
yeah there's a whole whole quagmire
regulations in fact so we are a Delaware
c-corp standard C Corp but we're a
registered investment advisor so the
capacity in which we place funds it does
an RIAA so that means that we are only
taking capital from accredited investors
so wealthy investors plus institutional
investors so that means we're not
subject to the nastiest of the financial
regulations but we do still have to be
compliant with SEC regs and that kind of
stuff so we essentially have to register
with the SEC as a registered investment
advisor and then do some basic
accounting and compliance stuff every
year so it's a pretty common model most
many leasing companies leasing and
finance companies use that model our
investors that are not are not banks
they are a mix of angel investors so
individual investors who participate
through a debt vehicle for a particular
financing if you want to get really into
the weeds our particular financing
vehicle as a master feeder fun structure
so each investor invests in a feeder
fund which then itself invests in a
master fund and that master fund is the
entity that actually owns the asset so
you get some isolation of risk basically
you can have multiple feeders with
different sets of investors and
different risk profiles feeding into the
same master fund that's a pretty common
structure yeah you mentioned I guess so
you showed the the tool where you're
describing ok they have a lease and I
paid for a certain amount of time and
then you've got savings going on after
that so once the lease is over do they
own the equipment they do ok it's called
a dollar buyout or buck out model we're
in in sort of arcane American commercial
lot ownership can never change unless
somebody pay somebody something so it's
actually quite common to just have the
customer pay a dollar to the less or and
that essentially transfers title the
equipment to that so they get to keep it
yeah that's right it's a cat its
equipment lease or finance lease with
the least oh and model yeah I have a
question on the solutions I know there
are some players in the market already
so I mean comment they probably have
like a first mover advantage such as
General Electric so I know in my house
GE had that utility company be installed
the new smart meter from GE so I bet
that if there's any other smart energy
solutions may be G has a first mover
advantage because maybe I'll just
continue to use this the same solution
from GE yeah it's number one question
what is your advantage solution
advantage over existing firms like GE
number two is in terms of financing like
a big firms like GE GE Capital the
proper has much bigger in a financial
capability than sparkfun right so can
you comment sure yeah happy to on the GE
question it's interesting you mentioned
GE so they they do have a capital
provider at aspect of their business GE
capital and they do work in the
efficiency space what's really
interesting about them and other sort of
vendor financers is that they often
create the financing arm of their
business specifically to move more of
their own product ge is manufacturing
those smart meters and a lot of the
other technologies so they're interested
in making more sales of that equipment
but oftentimes they actually don't want
to be in the financing business right if
they can find capital partners that are
specifically designed with a low touch
kind of story light touch financing
model that they can partner with instead
of doing it themselves they often
actually want to outsource that to
companies like sparkfun so we're seeing
a lot of interest from companies that
have historically offered their own
financing solutions that actually want
to find third-party solutions in terms
of the first mover advantage yet there
are a couple of companies out there that
could potentially move into the space or
a couple of types of companies one is
traditional equipment leasing companies
right companies that have been doing
forklifts or commercial industrial
equipment leasing for for many decades
they certainly can move into the space
they lack a couple of important things
number one is install our relationships
in the efficiency space right it's it
that is a significant barrier to entry
is having installed relationships in
place and fully integrating with the
sales process of contractors because
it's a very different sales process than
you see in the traditional commercial
industrial
space so energy efficiency is kind of
unique in that regard so we build a
company that's specifically designed to
integrate with efficiency contractors
rather than with broader equipment
suppliers and they're often also not
focused specifically on the efficiency
space so some of the tools and kind of
customer experience that we're designing
around the pricing engine that you saw a
line the Installer portal some of the
technology and transaction
infrastructure that we're building is
all calibrated to energy efficiency and
certainly you know other companies are
going to move into this space that's why
would we frankly would like that to
happen it's sort of an all boats rise
with the tide scenario this is a big big
market and it's dramatically under
addressed so it's going to be a long
time before the kind of borders of those
empires start to smash up against each
other it's really i think this market is
really just trying to develop and as an
infancy yep of quantifying how much
people actually save you had on the
model what they're expected to save but
is there any way you can verify after
the fact like you've actually recouped
this yeah well coming from the
background of being a nerdy energy
modeler I would love I'd love to do that
fedora I'm sure would love to do that
too we're like big energy data modeling
nerds but unfortunately that's a problem
that were not particularly well
positioned to solve only because the
transaction costs are super high for us
so we initially considered a model where
we would do ongoing measurement and
verification of projects and actually
calibrate the lease payments of
depending on how much the customer is
really saving in actuality but the cost
of doing that are often quite high
relative to the size of the project so
we would we collect that data where we
can so if the contractor partner we're
working with is collecting it then we go
ahead and look at that and make sure
that we want to generally ensure
customer happiness and quality assurance
for the product but at the end of the
day we don't have a mechanism in place
to do true measurement verification yep
so you you mentioned that you've got a
very decentralized sales force and the
contractors that are out there that
local and regional guys that generally
don't have a strong background in
selling financial products and it is
into the efficiency stuff so as you
scale and that
that sales force that you have the order
selling to directly but not interacting
with the customers as much that grows
how do you plan to manage that that sort
of the training and support you have the
at growing for a sales force that's a
great question yeah we do have for that
reason we obviously you can't train
every contractor right if a contractor
is going to bring you five deals every
year or something that's tricky from a
transaction cost perspective but we
particularly focus on those contractors
that we think have high enough deal
volume to merit making an investment in
them so I'd rather have 50 really
high-quality engaged contractors that
are bringing us 20 to 50 deals every
year then I would have 500 contractors
that have our kind of sporadic and their
deal generation so a big part of that is
focusing on the right contractors and
then making relatively low cost but
still the right training investments in
those contractors so we do at least do a
video conference training for a couple
days we do a sales training for them to
help you know what's the one of the
talking points around sparkfun what are
the talking points around financing we
also do operational training so we talk
to their administrative staff to say
here's the process you've got to follow
we lay it out really clearly so that
basically after that they're ready to go
sell and they're ready to go move deals
through the pipeline really quickly so
it is going to be one of our challenge
the basically a second tier customer
acquisition cost right contract your
acquisition cost but I think one that's
that's addressable with a little bit of
light touch training yeah
yeah that's a great question everybody
smart people will the first question the
last is what's like really what's the
default risk on that because it seems to
it seems too good to be true the default
risk there's pretty good data on this
the default risk ambient lee from data
collected from the vermont energy
investment corporation and a couple of
the group's is incredibly low in the
efficiency space it's actually in the
point five to one point two percent
range that's historical default that's
not projected that's what's actually
happened to the efficiency leasing space
it's pretty darn good the reason for
that i think is is a couple things one
is that there's a self-selection effect
for a company that wants to do energy
efficiency so if i'm a new startup
pre-revenue focused on my core business
i'm probably not going to take time to
think about shaving off by over ten
percent for my costs via energy
efficiency so companies that are
thinking about efficiency sort of by
definition have their [ __ ] together
right they've been in market for a while
they're looking to squeeze out cost
efficiencies there's another effect it's
kind of an interesting psychological
effect where efficiency is perceived as
super core to the operations of a
building so if we come in and install
some light bulbs even though you know
it'd be easy to replace those light
bulbs if necessary if they default on
that lease and we come like unscrew
their light bulbs which we generally try
to avoid but that's sort of the nature
of nature of the business right you
can't go rip an HVAC system out of a
church but you can unscrew a light bulbs
from a small business so there is some
asset recoverability here but from their
perspective you know that light is sort
of core of their operation so they look
at the light they're like they see that
as a course service so if they have a
lease book all the other debt that they
currently hold and they are going to
default on some of that debt they're
less likely to put efficiency towards
the beginning of that of that list
that's sort of the effect that we've
seen so ambient default and you know in
small project market is around one
percent range or lower certainly
segments to that market or higher
segments of the market or lower one of
our biggest investments was in really
good small project underwriting we're
working with with a guy named Sulaiman
Khan he's a has built was a former
finance guy who's then built several
solar leasing companies since then who
has designed an underwriting model for
us that incorporates balance sheet and
income statement and for me
to predict default rates so our hope our
pricing for every deal is based on a
risk-based pricing approach where we
look at potential negative cash flows
resulting from defaults and then price
the deal such that our overall IRR on
the deal to investors is going to be
sufficiently high to meet their demands
even in the event of default so it's a
core focus of ours one that we've
invested significant tech and and
finance talent in and I think one we
have a solution for yep you know what
sorry yeah you here's how you sort of
got to some of those savings numbers on
the end because like efficiency can be
so many different things like it's not
just light bulbs and a single efficiency
project and have a lot of different
technologies and guilt in it just
curious how you manage to simplify that
too like there's there's your number yep
that's another thing that we we aren't
in the business of detailed energy
modeling but our contractors are so our
approach to that is we don't do the
energy assessment ourselves but we check
it to make sure it's ballpark correct so
what we'll do when we bring out a
contractor it's actually answers your
question from before a little bit to
about training up contractors is we
don't just accept every contractor
willy-nilly we put them through a
vetting process so we call a couple of
their references we talked to projects
they've worked with before look at their
business history and importantly your
question we look at their savings
estimate methodology so we make sure
that because usually these guys have
some sort of spreadsheet or internal
software that they're using to estimate
savings sometimes it's a simple
spreadsheet with a savings factor and
sometimes it's a more complicated
building energy management system or
energy modeling system but either way we
look at it we make sure that the
methodologies they're using are
consistent with ashtray protocols and
investor confidence project protocols
and a whole range of other there are
some sort of specifications out there to
make sure they look good so we have
confidence that contractor is providing
decent savings estimates not super
precise always but they don't have to be
super precise for financing to make
sense and then on a project-by-project
basis we do a late technical review to
make sure that they're not knocking
something totally out of the out of the
ballpark yeah this is a question from
our blueprint for efficiency livestream
audience and is your preference for
working
hi for working high-volume contractors
conflict with the goal of accessibility
many contractors in the space are small
hence potentially less efficient from
your point of view yeah that's a great
that's a great question so far we have
not run into that barrier I think
because the space is so large it's going
to be a while before we have to start
optimizing to that level so right now
obviously we do show a preference for
the high for the high volume contractors
but we have we haven't turned away a
contractor yet because their volume
wasn't high enough I think that might be
something we need to start doing in
future but it all depends on how our
cost curve looks once we get into market
and it's very possible we can accept
contractors that are you know that are
generating two three four deals per year
it all ultimately shakes out to what our
relationship management costs are for
those contractors so I'm optimistic yeah
so do you have an in-house engineered
team that designs like energy efficiency
solutions based on I don't know ashrae
90.1 stuff or just our only contracts
contractors do that take what's down the
contractors do the heavy lifting on that
so we imagine a cash sale a normal cash
sale where a contractor is going to a
customer and saying here's a lighting
upgrade you should do here are the
specifications here's the proposal
here's the cost right the contractor is
doing all of that normally as part of
their standard sales process all we're
doing is just coming in and saying okay
the customer looks good from a credit
underwriting perspective the contractor
looks good from a technical perspective
on the project we're going to provide
financing for this deal so everything we
do is light touch we often call
ourselves a light touch financing layer
it sort of comes in on top of that
normal sales process so we do have a
single engineer in-house currently is
also our director of operations but it's
really all we need for now so we do that
light technical review so we take 15 or
30 minutes to look at the project look
at the inputs look at the sizing of the
system make sure that it's appropriate
for the building size some basic checks
like that but the heavy duty engineering
lifting is all done by the contractors
so the question I'm ignoring you sorry
so I was going to ask so what do you
think about the potential of a
partnership but you know like one of the
mammoth contractors like JC I or
Honeywell or Siemens down
Road and what sort of what mechanisms
did they use right now for financing
these size projects that you know kind
of contrast it's for fun yeah I think
the potential for those partnerships is
very strong I think right now they are
still figuring out exactly how they want
to handle the small project market do
they want to ignore it entirely do they
want to just sell product into that
market but not offer financing solutions
do they want to try and compete by
bringing up their own financing
solutions so there's a bit of
decision-making to be done I think in
the in the large-scale contractor space
but I do see significant opportunities
just like I was talking about partnering
with vendor financers who don't really
want to be in the financing space also
quite possible we can start partnering
with larger contractors who don't really
want to be in the small project space
but also have enormous industry
connection and market presence already
so it'd be a sort of a shame for them to
waste that presence without offering a
financing solution so it's a good it's a
good question yeah a couple short ones
what what's the longest term payback
that you can offer and how easy are
these to transfer up on sale within that
period yep they are transferable month
sale we obviously have to redo our whole
credit underwriting process for the new
off-taker but not a huge deal if it
needs to happen we refer to avoid it if
we can the in terms of the longest
payback period so we recently made the
decision that not all of our leases have
to be cash flow positive for the
customer so you notice in that graph if
I slip it all the way to the left the
payments actually exceeded the savings
for a while we thought you know it's
important to frame energy efficiency as
cash flow positive and therefore we're
going to cap the minimum term at a cash
flow positive rate but at the end of the
day if the customer wants the financing
they get the business case for energy
efficiency and they just want to do that
least quickly to get it over with why
not let them do that so we don't
restrict the payback period on the
project itself right now we try to
target leases that last no longer than
five to seven years we'd like to go
longer than that in the long term
obviously that the temporal risk of
default increases when you do that but
so right now we're seeing leases usually
in the 22 to 25 six-year range yeah I
think I was wondering if you go into a
little more detail about the cost of
capital you
able to provide currently and maybe
where you'd like it to get to as you
improve efficiency yeah that's a good
question there's this interesting sort
of valley of death as it's often
described for new financing companies
where they can attract low-cost capital
at the beginning of their life cycle for
people who are just excited about the
idea right and then later in the process
when they've scaled to a couple hundred
million dollars in deals they can start
good finding you know starting starting
to find low-cost debt partners who can
offer capital in the mid to
high-single-digit range there's that
interesting valley of death though where
you're not quite a start-up who's just
selling the dream but you're also not a
well-developed established scalable
solution yet that's I think one of the
biggest challenges a lot of financing
companies face I think one that we are
pretty well positioned to address with a
lot of our current debt partners so we
are seeing have long-term interest I do
think in the long term we can get our
cost capital down and that sort of mid
to high single-digit percentage range
first couple deals are going to be are
going to be more than that but one of
the interesting interesting things we've
seen in this market is that some
customers care deeply about the APR that
you're offering though right so they are
going to dissect every number you give
them minimize your APR other customers
actually care less about that you talk
about a fifty hundred thousand dollar
lighting upgrade in a you know
commercial say a small business or
something and as long as they can show
that the cash flows are going to be
there and it's the cash flow positive
upgrade for them it's relatively low low
risk for them low touch low transaction
costs they actually are interested more
and just getting it done get it done
quickly and capturing those positive
cash flows and one of the things that
sparkling offers is that we let you drag
that slider all the way to the right of
that of that range so what's actually
happening in the fairly complicated math
that drives that slider is the interest
rate is increasing as you're doing that
but it's not it isn't increasing
payments as much as the duration is
decreasing payments right so you're
actually increasing your cash flows as
you do that so we're seeing a surprising
number of customers who care less about
interest rate than they do about cash
flow which are sort of uniquely well
positioned to address but I do think we
are and can be competitive on the cost
of capital front directly as well yeah
I know you're not tracking all of the
performance for all the projects but for
the projects that you do have
performance I'm wondering what kind of
energy efficiency improvements you're
seeing in terms of like percentage
savings in energy yeah well we're so
we're still early stage we we just
launched so our first to actually sign
our documents for your first project
like three days ago so we're really
stage we've got a strong pipeline in the
works we're actually seeing way more
interest than we then we can find while
we have the capital to but we're finding
when we're interest then we can sort of
scale to meet at this point which is
always a good problem to have on the
pipeline fret I can tell you from
personal experience there's always a
range of uncertainty around upgrades
right lighting we love lighting because
it's good paybacks easy to install easy
to recover in the event of default and
also it has very predictable savings so
you see in a lot of lighting projects
and this is from my experience at ICF
Dartmouth is that you you're often in
the like ten ten to fifteen percent
range of uncertainty around that because
it's a simple system as simple
parameters governing governing it but if
you look at something like an HVAC
system doing a full building retrofit of
the entire heating ventilation air
conditioning system there's a lot of
interrelated systems with complex
network effects that can be very hard to
anticipate what those savings are going
to be so like I said we don't have them
there's no spark fund specific data on
that and honestly I don't anticipate
that most of these small projects are
going to have really good measurement
and verification data but at the end of
the day it doesn't like it before it
doesn't necessarily matter that you have
a hundred percent confidence in exactly
what the savings are what matters more
is that you understand the business case
for energy efficiency and you know that
you're saving money relative precise
amount yeah I was I was curious from a
sort of a bigger picture perspective of
the potential impact of spark fund not
just in terms of number of projects or
dollars invested but looking toward the
future being able to have some sense of
you know our first five years of
operations save companies on average ten
percent of their energy or just things
like that so maybe a something to
consider for the future that's a great
that's a great point yeah and also
important for tracking things like
carbon mitigation and environmental
impact too I agree yeah I wonder if you
could talk a little bit about the
entrepreneurship side of a spark fund
you know particularly what are the
challenges or maybe lack of challenges
and finding investors and also sort of
long-term you know what's your strategy
what are you telling investors right now
your series days Bester's about where
the company's growing what the growth is
going to be like sure yeah it's a good
question well first of all obvious the
team we've built is incredible it's Ford
it's amazing to be surrounded by such
intelligent people every day I always
say that if you're the smartest person
in the room you're probably in the wrong
room right and the people I work with
every day or just deeply intimidating
human beings because they are so smart
but i also love them all to death pierre
our CEO and i have call each other our
work husband's as we spend 14 hours a
day together so we have a great cohesive
sort of startup you feel what's great
though is that we also have a much more
process-oriented kind of disciplined
approach to running the business we're
not one of these crazy Wild West San
Francisco startups no offense to San
Francisco startups but who are like how
we're a 500 million dollar valuation
what who cares about revenue like it's
all about user base at all this crap
right we're not one of those companies
we all most of us come from the
consulting world at least most of the
co-founders do so we are used to
thinking in terms of process and
discipline and you know we modeled all
of our costs and all of our revenue like
this it was like the third day that we
said we were actually going to start
this company we had that all modeled out
so I think investors have responded
really well to us because we bring that
that discipline of process focus to the
table and you don't see a lot of
startups that do that and I think as a
result of that Plus this being a market
that's ready to go investors have known
that it's ready to go for a long time
they've just been looking for a
financing vehicle that's ready to tackle
these challenges they've just been
chomping at the bit so we actually had
we raised our angel round a lot quicker
than we thought we would we actually
jump ship from our prior jobs before we
had raised the full round and just
raised it in a couple of months it was
very quick and then so that was very
much selling the dream with some
spreadsheets to back it up now what
we're selling is much more than that
we're selling the functional leasing
company that we have now built so we are
we have functional technology we have a
functional transaction engine backing it
up we have you know a leasing company
that works from end to end we're doing
our first project now so now the vision
that we're selling to investors is scale
it's all about all right we're going to
launch we're doing an eight million
dollar pilot fund right
now to kind of prove out the model and
then we're looking to scale dramatically
from them so we'd like to have one to
three hundred dollars under management
within the next couple years so the
challenges have been as far as
attracting investor capital have
actually not not been as great as we as
we might have thought they were there's
always sort of delay challenges there so
even an investor that's interested
there's a couple of months of closing
time typically where they go through a
diligence process and but we were lucky
to find a lead series an investor that's
really engaged and really fantastic
party to work with yeah uh what
geographic markets are you opening up in
now how did you choose that and where do
you see expansion sort of throughout the
country yeah it's a good question we so
we are not geography constrained at all
we have no boots on the ground ever
unless we do on-site training for
contractors otherwise it's all email
email and website based so that means we
can go essentially anywhere so that our
geographic focus has emerged sort of
organically from where our contractor
relationships are so our first
contractor partner we've known for like
four years is based in mason ohio it's a
small primarily lighting installer there
and that has led to some more networks
and kind of the ohio area so we see some
projects there we've got i don't know
the latest number is but it's in the i
think the 70-plus signed contractors
right now or at least heavily interested
contractors that are spread across i'm
just estimating but probably 20 20
states 25 states so no real geographic
focus and i don't see a reason why we
would need to the challenge is going to
come from expanding internationally
which we may do we made you to canada
relatively soon because it's a similar
market and similar regulatory challenges
but we are looking to go international
eventually as well both in terms of
projects as well as investors do
financing regulations affect what states
you can or cannot operate in they it's a
good question they don't affect it in an
absolute sense but every state has its
own sort of hodgepodge set of
regulations that we have to comply with
so without risk of boring everyone
including myself there's like eight
different things we have to check in
every state to make sure that
we are compliant so there's usury laws
we have we have a meme wall at the
office so our Director of Operations
likes to keep us in line so she started
making usury jokes so one day she rolls
up in her chair and goes are you serious
I we spent a lot of time about office
guys oh so anyway we checking state Rep
state level regulations is an important
part of what we do there aren't any
states that just completely disallow
this kind of thing but there are states
that place regulations on what the cost
of capital you can offer is or what the
interest rates you could offer sometimes
you have to get registered in the states
do business sometimes you have to jump
through a couple of regulatory hoops so
we have a review process that kind of
gets out in front of those challenges
and make sure that we have everything in
line in the state before we move into it
I have more of a comment going back to
your 400 billion so I've been in this
space I kind of helped create it in the
70s and it sort of not going to endorse
her in this sort of underserved
commercial space as an energy engineer
but also as a systems analyst and um the
400 billion that has been said a
McKinsey number right somebody's sort of
said yeah they said I McKenzie number of
audits that are going to get done and
all the soft costs you know there's this
great opportunity to make money yeah sir
the last part of my career I've been
trying to sort of turn the tables on
that so start from the outside saying oh
you know how many buildings there are we
know what it's going to cost to get them
fixed we know from sort of effluents how
fast that ought to take place to start
to match up a little bit with the
climate change yeah I mean we got to
turn down the fires right so to me we
got to turn down about the fires and
maybe a million or two million
properties a year that's the pace we
need to be at in this sort of commercial
space there I don't know the number but
I think there are 15 or 20 million
buildings that we're talking about
you're thinking about them is an asset I
mean the goal ought to be I mean you've
got kind of a niche space I think there
is a number i don't know if it's the 400
billion but the part where we know how
much cellulose and how many you know air
handlers need to be bought yes stalled
we can figure that number out I mean
it's probably I don't know if we were
going to do a million buildings a year
maybe 15 billion dollars a year yep and
we ought to be but I caution young
people is up I mean the idea of making a
living in this space is sort of contrary
to the need which is to get the job
finished so you know I've been at it for
40 years the list is almost the same
today as it was when I started 70s how
much of a debt we got to figure out so
you can into the pace i mean i think
that's right or scale and that that is
the word but i think it's sort of a
quantumly larger number than you're
talking about if I was in a sort of you
know fledgling analyst position or
engineering position right now be
thinking about how to really get this
thing moving rather than how am I gonna
make my money in it totally no offense
yeah well that and that is that was the
starting point for first part fine I
that's a really good point and it's
funny your your point about thinking
about this at the macro scale not how
much of this market can we capture but
where do we need to get for a
sustainable economy for an
energy-efficient economy is where we all
started from so I came I came from
working on climate change background and
she started in that kind of advocacy
background and in sitting around
thinking about okay I don't want to work
on climate change for the rest of my
life what's the most impactful way that
I could do that and it the logical
answer after kind of thinking about the
market for a while and thinking about
where our skillset slide as consultants
and financial analysts was getting more
capital into that market so really the
genesis of spark fund was that goal that
you're talking about it's you know at
some point you have to say okay there's
there's an economy-wide challenge and
that is to address that systemically
across the entire economy is going to
take policy right it's going to take a
lot of companies approaching us for a
lot of different directions but it's
also going to take policy it's going to
take pricing energy
appropriately for the social cost of
that energy it's going to take you know
favorable policies at the state level
and the federal federal level to get
more energy efficiency done it's going
to take a sustained systemic effort but
then it's going to take a lot of
companies like sparkfun rising to the
challenge to meet to meet that demand so
from the perspective of running a
company I'm a big kind of a big believer
that you have to sort of your defined by
the battles that you don't fight and
it's better to try and solve a small
challenge and achieve as close to
perfection as you can in that market and
then grow based on that success so our
philosophy is very much around you know
we're not going to be four hundred
billion dollars tomorrow we're going to
eight million dollars today we're going
to do it really really well and we're
going to prove that this works and we're
going to encourage others to enter the
market and try and make all those kind
of boats rise with the tide but I tell
you what none of us are in us to make
the money that the four co-founders were
the four lowest-paid employee that
sparked fund until two months ago so
that that is our that is our driving
philosophy cool thanks guys